all right let's get into it we got big
changes I think the biggest one for a
lot of people the one that was rumored
was battle royale coming to you black us
for confirmed has been confirmed it's
called black out I'm just gonna skip to
that in our notes one of the quotes we
have is wanted to do a survival game a
battle royale game the black ops way and
then he and then he yelled which is
really good it's made my favorite part
of this room if you didn't catch the
street whoa the microphones are being
weird
I don't worry that's just our headphones
okay uh sorry the headphones were being
weird and I sounded like I was coming
from another dimension which is kind of
fitting with black ops but anyway um the
map has elements and characters from the
whole black ops series that battle
royale map you can play as Rezanov
Hudson Mason etc yep you know those boys
use items and weapons from black ops
history like the RC car mm-hmm I seem
like that's actually probably the most
interesting thing is because black ops
as a series starts in the 60s and then
has like the 80s and then like 20 20 and
then adds like 20 60 so they can kind of
get real weird and with like the variety
of weapons
yeah occasions they have a lot to work
with for that mode just because it's
been like what ten years right yeah it's
also the biggest cod map ever made which
I guess it kind of has to be if it's
gonna be like oh we all literally the
freezing was like like we'll drop you in
a large map and it was like alright you
know what this is like where we drop
infra so that's the interesting thing is
that they said oh it's a bunch of
different blackops maps come on together
and I was like wow that work and I'm
like oh it's like a battle realm out
it's like alright bro we drop it in nuke
town yeah up a nuke town today
actually I would totally well nuke town
would be overrun I'm sure everybody
would be like let's drop nuke towns for
Fidel Castro's Villa
that's my preferred drop of choice so
there's that I guess before we get into
trailers and stuff the game has
in addition to blackout three other kind
of pillars solo missions multiplayer
zombies and the force being black Battle
Royale so the narrative is through all
of them right right and it's you know
characters will talk to each other in
multiplayer and there will be returning
characters from black ops and all that
but they did say that it's not a
traditional campaign which we'll get to
in a little bites like a snack that in
there at the end yeah
combat is more tactical mm-hmm there's
weapon changes for example new
animations and recoil patterns your
weapon is up at all times I think would
you like would you like to do the honors
of the exact phrasing we got boots on
the ground on the ground guns still up I
I love it also underwater gun play which
is returning yes I met in three as well
health changes it doesn't regenerate
instead there's like a healing button
and you kind of like inject yourself
right you know how you do when you like
to heal yourself recovery is a more
tactical choice I think the impression I
got from it was that it was tactical but
also rather than you just going like
boss the wall guns blazing and then
dying and having to respawn three the
thinking is you'll stay in the combat a
little bit longer work more with your
teammates yeah and so I was curious I'm
curious to see how it affects like the
high like respawn rate in a typical like
in team deathmatch because usually
you're like you go you kill three people
you die and you respawn you have to like
reestablish like where everybody is so
maybe that'll change that there's also
new skills and items well not new well
flamethrowers aren't new but there's
grappling hooks we got we saw some riot
shields yep I'm ARB wire and traps lotta
they just looked at siege what can we
use from that there's a guy who looked
just like to chocka chocka yeah
really quickly we'll get into the
multiplayer but you know the
single-player they really snuck that in
at the end which oh it's not a
traditional camp a but anyway below us
so it's not a traditional Call of Duty
campaign instead they're specific you
take specific characters through solo
missions each has like a unique
backstory and its own challenge and
stuff like that
still with the call of duty set pieces
where you know you're thinking like oh
the big boats or whatever I figured they
had to get that in somewhere because
what else are they gonna make their
trailers out of true and then also it's
set between black ops 2 & 3 so cool
alright let's get into multiplayer I'm
gonna pull up the trailer do it here
normally Michael does the switching so
it's a whole thing but anyway we got
several specialists confirmed some
returning so we have Rouen serif and
firebreak returning from three yeah and
then recon crash and torque of
everyone's recons does what he sounds
like
and then I know there's like more
details but it's not super I wasn't
super clear on like what all the
specific abilities were but yes you like
riot shields right they kind of just
went into it pretty quick yeah but there
there seems to be much more of an
emphasis on the equipment yes which is I
think why they made the decision for
guns always up it's because I imagine
the problem is do you introduce
something like equipment but if you were
to use equipment you can't shoot we
don't think you would have a lot of
players that are just like well I'll
just keep shooting and not probably
using my equipment so I think right
allowing you to keep shooting while
using your equipment is gonna encourage
players to want to actually like utilize
this stuff more often yeah and that is
gonna be probably the biggest change I
feel like - just the dynamic of the
multiplayer yeah cuz I feel like even
with three with the specialists it was
mostly just like different you know
another recon ability or I always used
battery cuz I love her just I just think
she looks cool this is there wasn't like
any specific reason where I needed to
use her so it seems like a little bit
your your choice actually matters a
little bit more there's a focus on
fast-paced tactical gameplay like we
said boots on the ground there was a
whole sequence in the via livestream
where they were like will there be wall
running no will there be thrusters
no so
this trend of trying to get a crowd
really excited about not having a
feature in a game they were like
remember how much you hated that well
guess what we took it away took it away
yeah so utilizing specialist skills in
tandem is the big thing
the mini-map only shows enemies in
immediate in the immediate area they
have like a fog of war thing like your
typical scorestreaks which are returning
like a UAV will still do the same thing
but the mini-map is a little bit
different I won't notice at all because
I only play it's hardcore because I hate
mini myths that's fair I think that's a
smart change though like yeah other
college IDs you kind of just stare at
that mini-map right for like a you know
red arrow to show up and then you shoot
them so that makes a lot more sense and
then it makes the recount ability which
is just pulsing Widowmaker from you
Janell Roger
but vision pulls through there yeah like
that makes that more valuable and you
know they're trying to go for again like
teamwork of like oh you can overcharge
another person or when you do this it
gives it to everybody on the team right
definitely more tactical the other thing
that they mentioned was weapons have
unique attachments so the and they're
specifically designed for that
particular weapon type and they don't
carry over to other weapons so they're
just trying to make weapons I think that
what they said was they want each weapon
to feel like a character or they like
treated weapons as characters when they
design them so to get like a specific
feel from a weapon I don't know how much
I care about that necessarily
yeah I mean they've always been like
pushing each games trying to push like
weapon customization make that more
important so that seems like the logical
next step to try and like make that even
feel more of unique ya know how much I
particularly care about that yeah at the
end of the day everyone's still just
gonna find out which are the three best
weapons yeah let's see we talked about
the teamwork and specialist buffing
teammates etc laying traps like the
barbed wire kind of setting that up
certain gear sets for specialists so
some weapons can't be used by certain
specialists obviously and then for
competitive player
it will have league play which was
mentioned very briefly in the livestream
but something to keep in mind and then
so that was all that was like the first
first bit and there's this extended
zombie section Oh like so much because
it is Treyarch right the there they're
the they're the original zombie people
they are there daddy zombies as Michael
would say you caught a recent episode
Michael like that free slips um so yeah
so this is the first this is 9 I believe
it's what is called I think so yeah or
yeah it's just the first one it's
basically you see this like kind of like
ritual with a cauldron I think in the
notes we were taking for news I just
wrote like cauldron magic a question
word time-travel yeah and then you go
back which you'll see into a gladiator
arena and fight zombies with swords axes
Spears and shields I'm just going to
zoom to that because that was probably
the right there yeah it's um pretty
brutal it's such a different change of
pace and here's the I know right it's
she looks like that girl from the ad
campaign for Elder Scrolls online yeah
so there's this I I'll admit I was kind
of like hmm
write about the sword and shield any
guns in this at all yeah and I was
thinking do they not have guns on this
particular map and the other map which
we'll talk about in a sec they do have
guns yeah that seems a more traditional
experience but then this in this real
out there freaking crab monster comes
out by some Resident Evil ship yeah I'm
kind of about that honestly so there's
that and I don't know like for me I I
just don't know how to feel I don't know
how to feel about the sword and shield
combat but I think one of the biggest
things was that that wasn't the only
zombies thing they showed normally
zombies is like a slow roll out right
but late one night showed no they put
one every deals yeah and this time they
showed three different zombies modes
that will launch with the game which is
crazy
so this is the next one this is voyage
of despair which is an objective based
mode set on the Titanic and I'm gonna
skip ahead to the zombies part as well
because yeah you can imagine how the
Titanic looks I'm gonna be honest the
opening set up it sounded really cool as
a videogame of like oh it's a four
player co-op where you have to steal
stuff from rich people on the Titanic
I'm like I'll play that and they're like
oh but it turns into zombies game I'm
like I guess that's okay yeah
also these zombies are turning into
statues in like chess yeah they like
that's weird it's weird they're clearly
doing something different right they're
doing something different with zombies
because the last like Treyarch zombies
thing we had was you know the
collections the like black ops
collection zombies we made all the maps
down which I reviewed but yeah so
they're clearly taking a totally
different tactic until you get to this
final map they showed which is I only
showed a teaser not really mattered but
final mode they showed which is blood of
the Dead and this is classic zombies
mode maps so they're giving you a little
bit of both right they're giving you
some of the like oh we're changing it up
or taking it up and then they're also
like but remember how much you loved
zombies yeah it seems like care about
the zombies lore it has the original
like choruses from the original like
world at war and they've been in every
black ops game as well mmm-hmm but it's
like it's it's kind of weird like I
think most people think of zombies they
think of the weird cameos or Jeff
Goldblum's you're Sarah Michelle Gellar
is not gonna but there is like an actual
like consistent cast in timeline that
like the hardcore zombie fans really
really enjoy so seems like there's those
boys there including that for the but
for people who enjoy that know which is
which is good yeah um I know my brother
will really be about that there's also a
zombie rush mode which is a simplified
mode they said you could play it
single-player and still enjoy that
narrative right it's meant to be more
evergreen so there will be timely events
and season events called callings but
like trying to do that whole live
services thing yeah introduce a new
zombie they also talked about
customization for zombies so you can
like change the zombie speed health
parameters stuff like that to kind of
customize the mode to your liking which
i think is interesting that's really
cool actually yeah I think that's my
favorite things that they talked about
with zombies and then it'll have BOTS
support and a tutorial and stuff like
that just kind of helping people ease
into it it's kind of what they were
talking about I'm glad has BOTS like fit
up the campaign you want more like
single-player options so right then
Dinkley boxes is a really good idea yep
and then finally just some general
release info it's coming to you ps4 Xbox
one and PC on October 12th which is
earlier than normal for Call of Duty I
think that's notable the PC releases via
battlenet which is the first time like
just exclusively battlenet yep Papa Jeff
made an appearance Papa Jeff yep they're
working with Blizzard and B knocks on
that on that PC version and it'll have
fully customizable graphics options
dedicated servers multi screen blah
right um so they're really trying to
optimize the PC experience this
turnaround which I feel like is like oh
you were you weren't doing that before
yeah I'm like how is that just now the
thing you're doing um they've had a
weird history with PC ports yeah
sometimes they do really good job at
other times were like hey this doesn't
feel great on PC so well we'll see um
the beta is coming later this year
doesn't have a date yet but it will have
multiplayer impossibly black out which
is the name of the battle rail right
that I feel like that needs to be in a
beta X that's the big thing everyone
right you want to see how it plays I'm
interested to see like how it'll compete
in the battle royale space cuz I feel
like we've seen some recent competitors
struggle like radical Heights sure there
are a lot of issues around that one but
yeah radical Heights has a lot of
problems to be fair not just the battle
royale space being kind of dominated
right but I do you think I'm interested
to see how that plays out right
especially because this is the first
like triple-a franchise
Epic's a weird a weird case but like
yeah they're like this is the first big
triple a franchise to have a battle
royale mode added I wonder how that's
going to like affect it because you're
gonna naturally get a lot of players
just by the pedigree of being Call of
Duty great so they have like a kind of I
don't know like a good head start
yes they really do I'm I don't know I
know I wonder if I'll get my dad into
battle Royales my dad is a really big
shooter player but he he mostly plays
Call of Duty just cuz you know he has
the one game that he you know you don't
learn a bunch of new games all the time
which I get I wonder if he'll be like oh
this is really cool or he'll be like
what the [ __ ] I'm interested to see how
it plays with fans who aren't
necessarily like you know they're fans
of Call of Duty the way Call of Duty is
not you know so yeah there's that black
ops for yeah we know a lots more about
it now
yeah coming out coming out soon right
October October 12th over which yeah I
can't believe how soon that is that's
weird early for call duty yeah I imagine
I don't think they said why but I
imagine it's because they don't want to
get in the way of Red Dead Eye I would
put money on it being right said so yeah
there's that call duty next up a game
that's not coming out early is a big 2k
published sequel currently unannounced
however we found out during an earnings
report that this sequel unnamed untitled
unannounced has been delayed so it was a
little bit of a weird story yeah take 2
confirmed that meperidine take 2
confirmed that this game the M&S game
was delayed by saying quote the highly
anticipated title from one of two K's
biggest franchises which had been
planned for release during the current
fiscal year is now planned for launch
during fiscal 2020 to allow for
additional development time we remain as
excited as ever about this title and
expect it to enhance our results next
fiscal year fiscal 2020 for those who
don't know
is from April 2019 through March 20 2015
at 20 honey release necessarily but I do
want to point out he says a highly
anticipated title I'm like how can you
anticipate something that hasn't been
announced besides just wishing
just be sure you know like oh I just
wish that this exists I anticipate I
anticipate its existence swoon they're
really dancing around it because I feel
like this has to be Borderlands 3 that's
like the obvious I think the two options
that around the office we came up with
would be either Borderlands 3 or a new
Bioshock would be the two that we were
kind of like it's either one of those
funds because what else would it be if
you have an idea listen in the comic but
I mean we had them saying a couple days
ago where Randy Pitchford was making
like a weird magic metaphor on Twitter
Oh Oh we'll get into any picture we got
that got lost
anyway I'm pulling up Borderlands 2
b-roll just so we have something to look
at so yeah take two said there is some
marketing money being spent on this game
the Sun announced game during the fiscal
year the current fiscal year which lasts
from April 2018 through March 2019 so we
just entered this fiscal year which
means we'll find out what the game is by
next March
hopefully unless they delay the
announcement or something what the game
actually is all up to speculation but
gearbox had teased that a new board
lands game was in development back in
2016 in PAX East right a gearbox CEO
Randy Pitchford also mentioned Borland
sarena tweet thread that makes it sound
like it won't be at e3 so this is the
thing where Randy Pitchford kind of went
off the rails on Twitter a little bit
the thread was about a magician named
Todd Robbins and how people quote hold
on to what we want to believe while
discounting the truth if it contradicts
that the pitch was a huge magician like
that's the side hobby is he's into like
show magic I know it's like bonkers to
me the quote is for example I could
write it out now precisely and
specifically this is what randy
pitchford tweeted that Borderlands 3
will not be at e3 and many of you will
choose not to believe it
many of you will find a way to interpret
the intent to suit what you want to
believe regardless of what is true so
basically he's like I can tell you right
now it's not a t3 and some of you idiots
that's the subtext to me some of you
wouldn't believe me I kind of love that
it's like if that's the way you're gonna
try and like let people know that it's
not gonna be there but you can't
it's like explicitly say it yeah that's
a weird weird way to do it and they know
trying to love it I kind of hate it
and then and then pitchford also sent a
reply to for at least four different
people on Twitter that said is Berlin's
three the new half-life 3 - 4 - at least
four different people which is why we
are leaning more towards Borderlands it
being Borderlands that's this
unannounced game that's been delayed
rather than the other option that we
were thinking of which would have been a
new Bioshock I'm shocked because Randy
Pitchford was just like because he's
always like super coy on Twitter he's
always like mo capping for something you
know like he's he's very quiet at it so
we'll see yeah um so there's that it's a
little it's a little wild yeah the whole
thing around gearbox recently the last
couple years has been weird they had so
much goodwill built up over Borderlands
2 and then I feel like after that there
is like aliens colonial Marines there is
battle born and then you know just like
other weird stuff like Randy Pitchford
seems like a nice enough guy oh then
sometimes he says things that are really
douchey yeah and I don't know you know I
mean Twitter is hard because like for
example I will post a joke on Twitter
and people will think I'm serious and
explained to me who I am being mean fair
and I'm like that's a joke my dude yeah
so just I don't know like I feel like
the the like current like public
perception of Gearbox's in like a weird
place where like it used to be like
really on positive about them and now no
no they kind of like spent all their
goodwill
and they need they need to put out a
winner they do they do just may be why
they're taking their time on Borderlands
3 yeah we have a bunch of delay stories
yesterday because Metro Exodus and
Shenmue 3 were delayed right but Michael
and I were talking about how like you
know if something is delayed the end
results I mean like not I don't think
like it's always going to be better for
having been delayed but you don't want
them to release something that's like
clearly not ready right right like I
don't have a super I know a lot of
people get really disappointed by delays
or like even pissed off but for me I'm
like I got stuff so I can wait like I I
can wait for you to give me your you
know for you to present the product that
you are proud of right totally because
you know as big as a company is there
are still creators who work really hard
in those games and they don't want to
release something that's not ready
either so yeah there's that and then
lastly really quickly this is not a huge
huge story but I do we talked about this
yesterday and I want to just mention
that it happened is the xbox adaptive
controller has been announced that's the
controller that I don't know if we have
a picture in this article but here you
can see it as this thumbnail it's the
one that's for you know any players with
limited mobility to kind of reenact
controls on that controller and I think
it's a really cool piece of technology
and you know they partnered Microsoft
partnered with AbleGamers which is if
you know who Stephens bond is I might
mention him yesterday nominated for
trending gamer last year right um lost a
doctor disrespect but uh he works with
AbleGamers and they worked to make this
controller so it was it was worked in
collaboration with you know players who
have limited mobility and so I think
it's just a really cool thing and I'm so
excited to see what people do with it I
think this is rad I think this is a huge
deal like I you know it's such a huge
step to have something like this and
it's such a huge deal that Microsoft is
the one doing it yes as opposed to you
like a third party yes this is like the
console manufacturers saying like we are
putting all of this like time and money
into building this like significant like
product to help people out mm-hmm I
think that like that is just even if the
the you know controller itself ends up
having you know maybe certain issues or
isn't able to help anyone as I'm sure
you know it's it's tough to make
something that can appeal to everybody
yeah and I'm but I think it's just such
a huge step in the right direction yeah
it makes me so happy because I I've seen
you know other you know just
documentaries even about people who have
any sort of you know or differently
abled people who who really want to play
games but maybe can't hold a controller
and I think they they have been making
you know controllers and peripherals for
people with you know there's one-handed
joysticks and stuff like that but just
there was one that I watched we're
seeing somebody it was like somebody in
a wheelchair kind of like like that one
where it was um you just see the delight
on that person's face when they finally
got to play a game and and I think that
can be really powerful and really cool
and I'm just this is like really good on
Microsoft this is really great totally
and the variety seems like that you got
pedals you got the one-handed like
joystick like you said there was a
device where you could kind of put it in
between your legs to hit a couple
buttons and the way they have it set up
is like there's you have all these
different you know accessories and then
you have ports for every button and you
can put any accessory into any button so
you can completely customize it to your
specific setup that you need and I think
that is such a rad like smart way to
handle it mhm
and I'm just I don't know I think it's
so cool this is so cool it's really
happy that Microsoft's doing this yeah
me too
so yeah that's gonna be launching later
this year it will be a hundred dollars
u.s. which I guess I'm then actually
when I read that I can't tell if that's
higher not like to me I'm like oh that's
great like that's a great piece of
technology for $100
hopefully it's not prohibitively
expensive for people I hope not but I
mean an elite controller it's like a
hundred fifty well that's true this is
like less expensive than an elite
controller my dad got me one for
Christmas so I forgot how much they were
yeah so that's really awesome and I I
would love to see more people talking
about like how
use it and all the creative uses you can
get right I really want to see you want
to get some people's hands yeah for sure
all right um so that's the big news news
of the day we got black ops for we got
mysterious delays and cool controllers
lastly anime is it real
Oh anime is always real cool that's all
the time we have thank you for watching
thank you to Tony Wilson and Matt
Padgett and Eric Tay and Emily Conti and
Kevin whose last name I'm really bad at
pronouncing but he's on our news team
and he was checking stuff while Chris
Pereira is out of town and so we have a
whole team that makes us happen and
again really thank you for watching
every day we're here every weekday ok
spot daily we'll be back tomorrow see
you then bye bye where's the outro there
it is